un trofeo esperado por el fútbol francés
desde 1998 y es finalmente Karim Benzema
a quien lo ha recibido 11 veces nominado
entre los mejores jugadores desde 2008
el delantero francés completó este año
una temporada excepcional con el Real
Madrid el capitán del club español marcó
44 goles y realizó 15 pases decisivos en
todas las competiciones durante una
temporada la mejor actuación en toda su
carrera una recompensa individual que
perseguía desde hace tiempo
siempre está en mi cabeza pero cómo
hacerlo eso hay que fijarselo como una
ambición Y eso pasa por las grandes
competiciones y los grandes partidos
hoy recibe la más alta de distinción
individual del fútbol mundial y con ello
Karim Benzema desafía la historia
apodado como el niño terrible del fútbol
francés su nombre apareció en 2010 en el
caso zalla el nombre de una escort caso
del que finalmente salió absuelto cuatro
años más tarde pero en 2015 el chantaje
a su compañero de la selección francesa
Mateo Balbuena por un vídeo sexual
vuelve a manchar su carrera por este
caso fue expulsado del equipo nacional
por didida de Sam más de seis años
después recibe una pena de un año de
prisión y 75.000 euros de multa el 18 de
mayo de 2021 volvió a lo grande al
equipo nacional y se reveló como un
líder indispensable para de Sam